it's going to be an exciting afternoon
here and an exciting we are billing this
part of the program as the Friday night
debates and we're beginning not at night
but at 1:30 in the afternoon on the
topic of Islam threat or not to moderate
the panel it gives me a great pleasure
to introduce the war correspondent for
world daily one of the most watched uh
internet sites in the world a frequent
traveler to Afghanistan the Middle East
uh in Europe where among other things uh
he is a panelist on the French version
of Meet the Press so if you're a fan of
kiosk in Paris you already know Matthew
Sanchez please join me in welcoming him
now and the very difficult task of
getting this program going
okay
good afternoon it's a pleasure to be
here um just a couple of personal
comments before I became a war
correspondent uh I had the pleasure of
going to Kuwait and going into Iraq with
our troops American forces and I met a
lot of different people my idea about
Islam was very limited but I recall
being a raditi and celebrating Ramadan
and being with a lot of different people
who were Muslims and uh and just feeling
how much it resembled Christmas uh
people got together families ate and it
was a big celebration there was nothing
violent about
it that was always juxtapose
with acts of violence that took place
from islamists who during that ratti
celebration 1997 of last year exploded
uh a car bomb and ended up killing up
killing the host of the party where I
was that day and that was a gentleman
named shik satar so is Islam a threat or
is it a peaceful religion
honestly I couldn't tell you and I think
a lot of you are here asking some of the
same questions how much of a threat and
how much of an involvement we in the
United States will have with this force
that seems to be
growing here to discuss this for Two
Gentlemen who are much more intelligent
than I ever will be on the subject um
I'm going to bring up Dr Daniel Peterson
he's a professor of Islamic Studies at
Brigham Young
University he has completed a biography
on the life of
Muhammad to debate the doctor will be
Robert Spencer Robert Spencer uh you may
know him by some of the the books that
he he has two two New York Times Best
Sellers one is uh the truth about
Muhammad and uh he's also published the
politically incorrect guide to
Islam so these gentlemen will will be
debating and hopefully will answer some
of those questions that a lot of you
here are wondering as well at the very
end I I hope to open up the debate to
you and have you ask our panelist some
questions okay without any further Ado
let's bring up Dr Daniel Peterson from
Bri Brigham Young
[Applause]
[Music]
University there's no clear answer to
the question whether Islam is violent or
peaceful for one thing there's no single
platonic archetype somewhere out there
called Islam there are and always have
been competing Islams each claiming to
be the authentic one just as there's no
single monolithic Judaism but rather as
the great scholar Jacob nner has
observed Judaism and just as their
Catholic Protestant Orthodox Quaker and
many other christianities Sunni Islam
differs from Shi Islam and Sunni Islam
alone recognizes as Orthodox four
distinct schools of legal thought and
this isn't to mention Sufi or mystical
Islam which transcends the Sunni Shiite
divide nor such sex as the wahhabis and
others further the question's too black
and white obviously one cannot
simplistically pronounce Islam a
religion of Peace Muhammad was neither a
protog Gandhi nor some kind of 7th
Century Arabian flower child but it's an
equal and opposite era to depict Islam
simplistically as an ideology of hatred
violence and oppression like every other
religious faith and every other
institution involving humans Islam's
historical record is mixed with those
cautions stated a better way of phrasing
the topic of today's discussion would be
is Islam inherently violent in all its
forms or not to which my answer is no
before I set forth some of my reasons
for this answer in the painfully limited
period allotted so many disagreements So
Little Time permit me to say where I'm
not coming from I'm neither a Muslim nor
an apologist for Islam I'm a believing
Christian nor am I a left Winger or a
cultural relativist I don't believe that
the Islamic world is beyond criticism
and I see much to criticize I don't
think that the connection between Islam
and terrorist violence is accidental or
coincidence moreover I'm a movement
conservative for what it's worth with
libertarian leanings a subscriber to
National Review since I was 13 who
supports the surge in Iraq and the war
in Afghanistan I am however a student of
Islam and of Islamic intellectual
history Muslims currently represent
nearly a quarter of the human race and
they're not likely to go away anytime
soon nor are they likely to simply walk
away from their faith so my fundamental
question to those who claim that Islam
properly understood is inherently
violent that it's inescapably hostile to
Liberty in Western Civilization is this
what would you have us do I don't
suppose though Sam Harris comes close
that anybody seriously proposes a
western war of annihilation against the
world's roughly 1.3 billion Muslims but
if Islam is inherently violent vient and
hostile I see no real alternative to a
permanent state of war between the west
and Islam I reject the idea
unfortunately though I think that our
harshest Western critics make such a
clash of civilizations more likely how
because Ironically in privileging those
readings of Islam that demand a
permanent state of war between the daral
Islam the Abode of Islam or submission
and the DAR harb the Abode of War a pair
of entirely non- quranic phrases
incidentally they read it exactly as our
most Ardent and impliable enemies do and
in arguing that this is the only true
and legitimate understanding of Islam
they agree with say KB Osama Bin Laden
IM zahi and other extremists in
declaring moderate Muslims to be kufar
or infidels this seems to me
catastrophically wrong-headed not only
because it's historically mistaken but
perhaps even more importantly because it
undercuts members of the Muslim
Community whom we ought to be cheering
on a few weeks ago I was driving with a
Muslim friend in Jordan we're living in
a stupid period of Islamic history he
told me I hope that people won't judge
all of Islam Islamic civilization and
Islamic history by this stupid period to
that in the context of this discussion I
add my hope that we in the west won't do
anything to support stupidity or to
delegitimize intelligence among our
Muslim neighbors the old Latin precept
first Do no harm can and should apply to
Intercultural relations as well as to
Medicine modern mujahedin do not believe
they're hijacking Islam Robert Spencer
rightly notes they believe they're
restoring its proper interpretation and
they're successfully convincing peaceful
Muslim Muslims around the world that
they're correct and they will continue
to do so for as long as peaceful Muslims
fail to formulate new and non-
literalist ways of interpreting the
Quran and the words and deeds of
Muhammad in his books however Mr Spencer
effectively argues that the wahhabis and
alq and their fellow Travelers represent
true Islam far from being extremists or
perverts of the faith he writes they
interpret its texts correctly they are
the people who actually dare to do what
Allah says to do he argues that
non-muslims who don't recognize this
live in a fantasy world and most ially
that moderate Muslims to the extent that
they exist are moderates either because
they aren't serious Muslims or because
they're ignorant of the real teachings
of their faith this is precisely the
position of say putb and the other
founders of today's militant islamism if
true it would be deeply disheartening it
would suggest that if Muslims learn
about their faith and follow it they
must logically practice the Jihadi
extremist form of Islam in my judgment
however this idea is not true as
outlined in John Kelsey's important book
arguing the just war and Islam there's a
serious inter Islamic conversation going
on and the moderates have a case and I
could not possibly disagree more
strongly with Mr speno and the wahhabis
when they claim that the mystical or
Sufi tradition of Islam which has often
expressed itself peacefully and
tolerantly is not true Islam to oppose
aggressive military Jihad Mr Spencer
says would be to turn against Islam
itself in seeing the war on terror as
not just as a war against Islam but as a
war on behalf of Christianity Mr Spencer
writes the view of Bin Laden and other
Jihad terrorists neatly coales with that
of the anti-christian theocracy writers
like Chris Hedges and Kevin Phillips Mr
Spencer's full throat had sustained
defense of the Crusades as Justified
defensive Warfare and his expressions of
gratitude to the Crusaders suggest that
he Hedges Phillips and Osama aren't so
very far apart on this matter and no
muslim who opens to the front his piece
of Mr Spencer's Politically Incorrect
guide uh to Islam to see the two words
that appear alone and in all capital
letters on it deos vult he's likely to
be reassured deos vol Latin for God
wills it was the Cry of the people at
the Declaration of the First Crusade by
Pope uran II in
1095 even many conservatives shy away
from naming the enemy Mr Spencer writes
for fear that it means war against a
billion Muslims but if Mr Spencer's
arguments are granted doesn't it it's a
PC myth he has written in the context of
a discussion not of Fringe terrorists
but of mainstream Islam and Islamic
history that we can negotiate with these
people quote
unquote